hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer question
from one of my newsletter readers an
ally who is starting the business that
sell supplies to school so photocopiers
toner printers are kind of stuff and
it's worried about the financing and the
resources to get the business going and
one of my advice and what to do so I'm
not only what i would suggest here is
again this is a type of a tough business
to be able to go and raise capital for
banks will probably not support you
unless you have really good credit
history and and for investors it could
be a tough slog to get that investment
money coming in i think your best option
here again is to go after your customers
and get financing through them so it's
not really a lack of resources that'll
hold you back its lack of resource
fulness so you don't need a lot of
resources that get started but you need
a lot of resourcefulness so what I'd
encourage you to do is try to get to
your customers ask them what they need
and see if you can a get them to buy in
advance so whatever purchases they need
can they know pay for it now when you
deliver in 15 days or 30 days or 60 days
or whatever it is I'd also look at ways
to be able to sell them on a
subscription package so if they're
buying a photocopier from you or
printers from you they're going to need
all the toner that goes with it so can
you sell them you know a package where
they get toner every month or every two
weeks or whatever it is and they pay for
that in advance so they get a slightly
discounted rate but they're paying for
it in advance and they know that they're
going to have it for the year for a lot
of businesses it's great because they
have some cost certainty so they know
how much they're going to be spending on
toner for the year so you're giving them
that cost certainty you get money in
advance where then you can use that to
buy other inventory and grow your
business and it's also great for them
because they get a light it's like
discount on the price of the product it
you saw so from your email sounds like
you have some margins to play with so I
definitely explore that option to get
the money you need to kind of launch
your business that way if you're really
tight I'd also look at selling the
products or services that
are really easy to get access to that
don't require a lot of capital injection
on your behalf so you can get access to
it faster get it into your customers
hands faster cheaper to kind of get set
up and then as you grow your business
you can expand into other product lines
so now I hope that helps I know it's
tough to get these types of businesses
started but it sounds like there's a lot
of opportunity from the email you sent
me so good luck start implementing those
ideas and let us know how it goes if you
guys like the video please give it a
thumbs up or leave a comment below I'd
love to hear from you I make decisions
on what new videos to create based on
those feedback and that the likes and
comments are really appreciate it and
makes me motivated to keep making these
videos for you guys so please please
leave one of those below and we'll see
you on the next episode
you